- A strong launch helps set
your app on the path to success.
This video gathers ten tips
to making your app launch
a great one.
You need a great app
in order to have a great launch.
Make sure your app measures up
by testing it against
the Android quality guidelines
on developers.android.com
and then review the guidelines
for each form factor
you're supporting--
from tablet to TV,
wear, and auto.
Age rating your app provides
users around the world
with assurance
about its content.
Once you've completed
the questionnaire,
your app will be age rated.
Local ratings familiar
to local audiences
will be delivered for
key markets around the globe.
The Play Store listing
is a critical part
of your app's marketing.
Impress them with how your app
would look on their device
using icons, screenshots,
graphics, and videos.
Set up store listing experiments
in the developer console
to test different graphics
and text as soon as you can
in order to make data driven
improvements to your listing.
Apps in the user's
local language
are more likely
to be downloaded.
Translate the listing's
descriptive text
and remember to translate
the text in screenshots,
graphics, and video too.
You can use
the app translation service
in the developer console.
Many of your potential users
will be on limited
data connections,
so apps with smaller APKs
will get more downloads.
You can reduce your APK size
by getting rid of unused
library dependencies,
implementing appropriate
animations and code,
providing resources for only the
most popular screen densities.
It's important to test to see
how your app functions
and fares before you launch,
so test against the most popular
devices in your target markets.
Get your user community to help
by taking part in beta tests.
And sign up for the Cloud Test
Lab in the developer console
to automatically test
your beta app
on hundreds
of popular physical devices
and receive detailed analysis
of any issues.
When you launch your new app
or game, you'll create interest
amongst prospective users
and established ones.
Don't waste this.
You might, if they can't get
your app or update
at the same time
as everyone else.
Keep your momentum by launching
on Android,
on all form factors
simultaneously
with your other platforms,
or try to let users
with other platforms know
that support is coming and offer
them a way to get notified.
The press and bloggers are
always looking for good content,
so let them have it
as early as possible.
Create a list of local
and global contacts.
Go for app and game bloggers,
but target vertical publications
too.
For example,
if you have a travel app,
also include
travel publications.
Create a press pack.
Include screenshots,
a summary of your app or game,
the pitch for what makes it
awesome or unique,
and something interesting
about your company.
Marketing your app is essential
to making it stand out
from the crowd.
Create a plan
to use social media,
video content,
app install ads,
and more.
Keep interest high
after your launch
with strong reinforcement.
Consider offers,
incentives,
and reminders
tied to specific events.
Once your app is live,
users will have questions,
find issues,
and look to you for support.
There are several ways
to provide this:
monitor the contact email on
your app's Play Store listing,
create a Google Group to enable
users to post support questions,
consider using a third-party
customer support product.
Responding will keep
users engaged
and build customer loyalty.
For more information
on launching your app,
head over
to the distribute section
of the Android developer website
and check out
the launch checklist.
If you want more tips on how
to improve your app
or game's performance
and build a better app business,
check out the other videos
in the series
and download The Secrets
to App Success on Google Play.